- [Kelly] We were talking about your kids,
so what do they think of
your Tik Tok dance moves?
- [Jessica] So here's the
thing it's like, I'm like
basically they think I'm the
worst and I'm just like, can I
can I just remind you
that I'm Honey? I'm Honey.
- Yeah, exactly. Did you see the movie?
- I mean, and they're just
like "mom but when you are-
- Look at that booty! Look at that hip!
But look at the little one!
- They're like "mom, but when
you do what you just like
it just feels like
you're trying too hard."
- Look at that. No, it doesn't.
No, it doesn't. They're jealous.
Jealous of your moves.
- I was like, just let me live.
Just let me live.
- And have a good time.
I think it's so important.
Cause my daughter, she thinks
she's like, you are so silly.
Like even the movie ended last night
and the ending credits gone.
I know we have a thing in our house
and the ending song comes on.
No matter if it's sad or
happy, we have a dance party.
And we don't know why we
just get up and do it.
And last night they were kind of tired
and I just was like flailing around.
And I think it's like awesome
for your kids to see you kinda like that.
Cause then I feel like especially
this day and age, like kids
I don't know if they're
online, but it's like
they get so trapped into
that mentality of like
it's not cool or like I can't be myself
or people wouldn't accept me.
Or I won't get likes, cause
it's like a hard thing.
I think it's good you're
doing stuff like that.
- I think-
And I also think it's good
for them to like allow me to
be silly.
Like allow me to be uh
to giggle and allow me
to like be a person.
And then I feel like
they'll have more compassion
you know in life for everyone else
but also not, you know, for, for me.
- For y'all's relationship.
- And for our relationship,
which I think is good.
- I have to say they had to
think this was pretty cool
because you got Zac Efron into
one of your TikTok videos.
So I wanna show this video real quick.
- Okay.
- This is amazing. Like,
so they had to have thought
this was amazing that you got him in.
Did they think you were cool?
- They were like, wait, what?
Like is he? Did what?
They were like, is he coming over?
Like how did you get him to do this?
Like, like, is, does he
think you're a stalker?
Like they were so confused
about how it happened.
And I was like, I did
a job with him in Dubai
and by the way, he did a video with me.
- Yeah exactly. I was literally-
- What are we even talking about?
- It was so funny cause
my kids will be like
you know this person like,
yeah, but they know me too.
Yeah. I'm like, wait, what?
And like our kids, our kids don't care.
- They, they have no idea.